In this lecture, we'll be
using analytical models
to prevent heart disease.
The first step is to
identify risk factors,
or the independent variables,
that we will use in our model.
Then, using data, we'll create
a logistic regression model
to predict heart disease.
Using more data, we'll
validate our model
to make sure it performs
well out of sample
and on different populations
than the training set
population.
Lastly, we'll discuss
how medical interventions
can be defined using the model.
We'll be predicting
the 10-year risk
of coronary heart
disease or CHD.
This was the subject of
an important 1998 paper
introducing what is known as
the Framingham Risk Score.
This is one of the most
influential applications
of the Framingham
Heart Study data.
We'll use logistic regression
to create a similar model.
CHD is a disease of the blood
vessels supplying the heart.
This is one type of
heart disease, which
has been the leading cause of
death worldwide since 1921.
In 2008, $7.3 million
people died from CHD.
Even though the number of deaths
due to CHD is still very high,
age-adjusted death
rates have actually
declined 60% since 1950.
This is in part due to earlier
detection and monitoring partly
because of the
Framingham Heart Study.
Before building a
logistic regression model,
we need to identify the
independent variables
we want to use.
When predicting the
risk of a disease,
we want to identify what
are known as risk factors.
These are the
variables that increase
the chances of
developing a disease.
The term risk
factors was actually
coined by William
Kannell and Roy Dawber
from the Framingham Heart Study.
Identifying these
risk factors is
the key to successful
prediction of CHD.
In this lecture, we'll
focus on the risk factors
that they collected data
for in the original data
collection for the
Framingham Heart Study.
We'll be using an
anonymized version
of the original data
that was collected.
This data set includes several
demographic risk factors--
the sex of the patient,
male or female;
the age of the patient in
years; the education level coded
as either 1 for
some high school,
2 for a high school
diploma or GED,
3 for some college
or vocational school,
and 4 for a college degree.
The data set also includes
behavioral risk factors
associated with
smoking-- whether or not
the patient is a current smoker
and the number of cigarettes
that the person smoked
on average in one day.
While it is now widely
known that smoking increases
the risk of heart
disease, the idea
of smoking being bad for you
was a novel idea in the 1940s.
Medical history risk
factors were also included.
These were whether or
not the patient was
on blood pressure medication,
whether or not the patient had
previously had a stroke,
whether or not the patient was
hypertensive, and whether or
not the patient had diabetes.
Lastly, the data set
includes risk factors
from the first physical
examination of the patient.
The total cholesterol level,
systolic blood pressure,
diastolic blood pressure, Body
Mass Index, or BMI, heart rate,
and blood glucose level of
the patient were measured.
In the next video, we'll
use these risk factors
to see if we can predict
the 10-year risk CHD.